was it right
what i did
ask me again in 10 years
try not to worry ollie i've been
worrying about john for years
he always comes back
soon after
the rel
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over
till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones and a
song of life and fire update video
well my friends it looks like we have
some very interesting news from the
hollywood reporter according to an
article written by james hibbard there
is a new jon snow sql series in
development at hbo the network has
entered into early development on its
first sequel to its blockbuster fantasy
drama a live-action successor show
centered on the fan favorite character
jon snow not only that but according to
this article it seems that even actor
kit harrington has agreed to renew his
role as jon snow should the series move
forward
the development signals an interesting
new direction on hbo's handling of
author george r martin's fantasy
universe in a move not unlike disney's
management of its star wars and marvel
brands where the streamer has found
success launching character-focused
sequel series such as one division and
obi-wan kenobi with ewan mcgregor
stepping back into his iconic role now
from a creative standpoint this new
john's new series could upend game of
thrones final season as the last word on
the fates of the surviving characters
and hbo's most successful and
emmy-winning series of all time in
theory this could open the door for
other surviving characters from the game
of thrones universe to show back up such
as arya stark sansa stark and many other
characters this news means there are now
seven different game of thrones series
in development in addition to the
upcoming house of the dragon series
which debuts in late august hbo has not
confirmed any of this information so as
of right now i would take this with a
grain of salt i don't know how accurate
the article actually is as a matter of
fact the dragon demands is already
saying james hibbard is lying i honestly
have no idea what to believe right now
i just woke up around 8 am and this
information was the first thing i saw
it's not even 30 minutes later and i'm
sitting here gathering my thoughts as we
speak now whether this actually happens
or not i do think this makes a lot of
sense if this would happen hbo would
most likely throw a lot of money at kid
harrington to bring him back and
although he may not have initially
wanted to step back into jon snow's role
he might reconsider if he doesn't like
any of the other offers hollywood is
giving him he wasn't the eternals but i
don't know anyone that liked it if he
became jon snow again he would
immediately become one of the most
famous characters on television
something i know has to be very tempting
especially if hbo would throw the bank
at him again i actually discussed this
very same thing happening in one of my
recent videos i said a lot of the game
of thrones actors would consider coming
back to westeros again once they realize
they might never work in something this
big again maisie williams has already
flirted with this idea before she
certainly sounds like she would be open
to acting as arya stark again and i
would bet she's not the only one now
would any of them coming back actually
makes sense as you all know game of
thrones left with a lot of open-ended
story lines at the end of game of
thrones season 8. not only that but
besides maybe daenerys targaryen jon
snow is one of their most recognizable
characters i think if hbo really wants
to find success after game of thrones a
jon snow successor show is more likely
to bring back a lot of the fans than a
house of the dragon show when you
consider every game of thrones fan knows
who jon snow is whereas only the
hardcore fans know about the dance of
the dragons now i don't want anyone to
think i'm saying a jon snow series would
automatically be a hit you would still
have to find great raiders to make the
show make sense just because fans
recognize jon snow doesn't mean they
will watch anything the character is
involved in he would obviously have to
have something interesting to do
now as we all know when game of thrones
ended jon snow is heading north of the
walwood ghost and a very small group of
wildlings as far as we know there's
nothing interesting left north of the
wall we were led to believe the white
walkers are dead but that doesn't mean
they have to stay dead forever there are
many different ways they could bring
them back as well as some of the other
characters we came to know and love in
game of thrones i actually wrote out an
entire season 9 for game of thrones
which you can find in my list of videos
now i'm not saying any of those ideas
are great ideas but what i did was have
daenerys get brought back to life by ken
vara an idea that was already
circulating around the internet
immediately after the final season was
over i also had brian stark be the next
evil villain something that could easily
be set up through his connection with
the three-eyed raven the children of the
forest and even the night king i had
already long suspected that the children
of the forest and the three-eyed raven
were not who we thought they were in
order for them to make john cena's story
interesting again they would most likely
have to bring him south to fight in
other battles or remove bran from king's
landing after finding out he is still
being influenced by a faction of the
children of the forest who are living at
the god's eye or jon snow would have to
come south again if daenerys and drogon
came back to westeros unleashing their
hellish fire again but i don't think hbo
would want to bring her back just to do
the same thing over they could expect
the fans to have the same reaction they
did the first time daenerys went mad now
another thing you could do is have grey
worm come back and kill jon snow when
and if he ever found out jon was south
again also if daenerys did come back to
life and she still had drogon how would
she react to jon snow murdering her
would she immediately want revenge or
would she be willing to set that aside
to fight for the greater good assuming
there was another evil force amassing in
westeros or even essos
now these are only a few ideas i will
throw out there for right now if you
want to know how a season 9 of game of
thrones could work go watch my full
season 9 rewrite obviously they would
need some great writers to flesh
everything out but either way there is
still some story to be told if they
really wanted to
since hbo has the rights to a song of
ice and fire they don't even need george
rr martin to sign on to it i'm not
saying that would be a wise decision but
they could move forward with the idea
whether or not they had his blessing i
mean they kind of did that with game of
thrones already after they no longer had
his novels to follow again i do want to
say i don't know if the article was
accurate i will need a confirmation from
hbo before i fully believe anything with
that being said i do think it could work
my final thoughts are mr harrington
might be willing to do this if hbo
throws him a lot of money and if he
thinks this would be a better option
than whatever offers he's currently
getting like i said he could immediately
go from being forgotten to one of the
most famous actors on television again
i also think hbo could make this work if
they hired solid writers there are a lot
of ways jon snow could have an
interesting story as long as they
created some conflict for him again i'm
sure they also wouldn't mind rewriting
game of thrones history through a new
show i'm sure they've already been
thinking about how they could make game
of thrones ending more digestible now
with that being said they could also
make things a lot worse if they bring
back these characters just to mess it up
all over again they would obviously be
walking a very fine line
and at the end of the day they don't
even need george rr martin to sign on to
it they still own all of the rights to
game of thrones in a song of ice and
fire so they could make just about any
show they want
now i am sure there will be a lot of
fans who hate the idea but just like
with house of the dragon i guarantee
they will be watching any new shows as
soon as they are released as always i
will let you know if any new information
is released regarding the new jon snow
show or anything else involving game of
thrones house of the dragon or the winds
of winter make sure you subscribe so you
can stay up to date on any and all
information i want to thank all of you
for stopping by and watching the video i
hope you all have a great day i will see
you soon
bye
so
[Music]
so
you